everyone wants to be someone we all want
a title a status a distinction something
to give our existence meaning as a child
we are asked what we want to be when we
grow up we are given the impression that
we are not yet enough a must long for
careers and titles in order to feel
whole and so we follow this thread
hoping it will pull our life into
meaning we all have something to
contribute something to work towards
something to be passionate about but in
the process of turning these some things
into goals and careers it is important
that we maintain separation between them
and our sense of life and self-worth if
we search for ourselves entirely through
our career goals we will never be
satisfied with who we find because
career goals never end instead we must
remember that we are all intrinsically
worth as much as what we decide we are
worth every human is an individual with
value and Wonder in their spirit and no
career achievement or lack thereof can
determine otherwise when we are young we
should be asked what we want to do when
we are older not who we want to be for
who we are is who we are
with or without career achievements the
moments of our childhood are not worth
less than the moments of our adulthood
just because we did not yet have a
career or status our ability to create
meaning and enjoy our self is often the
strongest as a child and we must
remember that we can continue to carry
this with us or through life independent
of our careers and statuses
when we acknowledge our intrinsic value
regardless of status will become like a
tree grounded and full of life and our
career accomplishments become like fruit
growing from our limbs providing
nutrients for the world but as the
seasons change and the fruit comes and
goes we can continue to remain as the
tree firmly rooted in abundance our
careers and accomplishments are
certainly major parts of our lives that
we should appreciate and take pride in
but if you neglect to embrace your
self-worth and sense of life outside of
them you have missed the point thank you
for watching if we found enjoyment and
value in this video please give it a
thumbs up share your thoughts in the
comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder